If you want to become a pilot, the FAA
requires you [music] to know which
documents must be on board the aircraft
anytime you go fly. And in this video,
I'm going to explain [music] those in
detail.
Welcome to Free Pilot Training. I'm Josh
and today we're talking about required
documents. And they don't call them
required for no reason. These are
required by the Federal Aviation
Regulations. In fact, this is the first
episode in our discussion on the federal
aviation regulations. And as we're going
through today's lesson, you're going to
notice that when we discuss some of
these requirements, I'll throw a
reference like this on the screen. It's
really important that you look these up
in the far aim when you get a chance.
And frankly, these are some of the ones
I would bookmark for the check ride. To
get started, let's take a quick look at
the three documents that every pilot
needs to have in their possession when
they fly an aircraft or when they act as
a required crew member. You'll find the
details of this requirement in FAR 61.3.
But if you want to fly or act as a
required crew member, you have to have
these three things in your possession.
First, you got to have your pilot
certificate. Then, you have to have a
valid photo ID. And I know this sounds
kind of stupid since the PPL or the
sport pilot license should count as an
ID, but they don't put your picture on
it because it doesn't ever expire. And
if you don't get any more ratings or
certificates, you're stuck with that
same card. Anyway, what constitutes a
valid photo ID? Well, it can be any of
these things right here. A state issued
driver's license. And if you're unlucky
enough to live in Washington DC or one
of the US territories, your license
counts as well. A government ID is fine
as well. It can be a federal or
stateisssued ID card. Then for my
military brothers out there, your
military ID card or your CAC card works
fine, too. You can also use your
passport or an airport security ID as
long as it gives you unescorted access
to security identification display
areas, whatever that means. In addition
to these, you can also use any other
form of identification that the
administrator finds acceptable. And who
in the world knows what this means? But
if you don't have one of these that we
just talked about, you can call your
local FSDO office and see if what you
have is acceptable to them. Yeah, I was
wondering if I could use my Costco card
as a valid ID.
Why not? It's got my picture on it. Last
but not least, you have to have a
current medical certificate. Now, sport
pilots don't have to have one of these,
but most other pilots do. And it also
needs to be the right type of medical
certificate for the type of flying that
you're going to be doing. I'll go into
more detail on this in a minute, but for
now, just know that you have to have a
current medical, unless you're going for
a sport pilot rating. This brings up an
important point. If you're just starting
to work on your private pilot
certificate, you have to have that
medical certificate before you can go
fly solo. So, it's a good idea to get
that scheduled as soon as possible.
Waiting until the last minute can
significantly delay your training. So,
get that done or else. Now, the only
time you don't need a medical
certificate as a private pilot is if
you're operating under basic med. I'll
go into a little bit more detail on
basic med in a future episode. There's
quite a bit to know about that. But if
you're not operating under basic med and
you're not a sport pilot, you have to
have all three of these in your physical
possession or they must be readily
accessible in the aircraft anytime you
go fly. And by the way, with the new
Mosaic rule, if you have a sport pilot
rating, you can get an endorsement to
fly at night. But in order to operate
under these privileges, in this case,
you will also have to have your medical
or your basic med paperwork in this
situation. And if someone asks you for
this paperwork, you're going to be
really sad if you accidentally left it
in your mom's basement. And that brings
up a good point. Who can ask me for
these papers? What are they going to do?
Pull me over in the air? I can't tell
you how many times I've heard this. And
I can't tell you how dumb people sound
when they say that because there are a
handful of people that can ask you for
these documents. And if you don't
produce them when they ask for them, you
can get in a lot of trouble. In fact,
here's a list of all the people that can
ask you for these documents. All these
guys right here have the right to ask
for your stuff. Don't think it just has
to be the FAA. It doesn't. Who am I
kidding? You guys are probably always
going to carry pilot credentials on you.
You never know when you might be on a
Delta flight and the pilot dies of a
heart attack. Excuse me, ma'am. I just
want to let you know I'm a private pilot
and I'm going to be seated in seat 24B
in case you guys need me. All right,
let's go into some more detail on these
medical certificates because you need to
make sure you have the right type. And
you also need to make sure that it's not
expired. Here are the four types of
medical certificates available. You'll
find all this information in FAR 6123.
But don't worry, Uncle Josh is going to
break it down Barney style for you. Now,
the main difference in all these
certificates is the type of exam that
the doctor has to perform and how long
the certificate lasts. In order to get
your private pods license, you're going
to need a third class medical
certificate. And once again, if you're a
sport pilot, getting the third class
medical may allow you to fly at night
under the new Mosaic rule, but you still
need to meet the training requirements
after you get that. First and second
medical are really for commercial pilots
and there's a little bit more to the
exam, but you only need a third class if
you're going for your PPL. Then once
again, there's basic med. But in order
to earn your private pilots license, you
have to pass one of these other three
first before you can use basic med. And
then there's some limitations if you do
decide to use it. Now, even though
you're probably only going for your
third class medical, let's talk about
these other two really quick because you
might decide that you want to make
flying a career. First class medical
exams are mainly for airline transport
pilots who want to operate as a pilot in
command. In other words, these would be
the captain of an airliner. These guys
need a first class medical certificate.
These certificates don't last very long,
and that's because the FAA wants them to
get looked at by a doctor more regularly
than someone like you, who's only flying
their Cessna 172 30 m to get a $100
hamburger. For pilots under the age of
40, first class medicals only last 12
calendar months. If you're 40 and over,
they only last 6 months. Now, one
important thing to keep in mind about
these things is that when they expire,
they aren't completely worthless
anymore. For pilots with the first class
medical 40 and up, when their first
class expires, it turns into a second
class for six more months, then it drops
to a third class. If you're below 40,
when the 12 months are up, it
automatically turns into a third class
medical certificate. So, you can still
fly, you just can't do certain things.
Now, notice how this says calendar
months. That just means that it expires
the last day of the month, 12 months
from this date. In other words, if I got
my first class medical on January 15th
of last year, my first class is going to
expire on January 31st of the next year,
then like we said, it's not completely
expired at that point. Now, it's a third
class medical. Keep in mind, a lot of
aviation timelines are tracked in
calendar months. So, this is something
you want to be familiar with. We'll be
discussing this more in a future video.
Next, we have the second class medical
certificate. In a nutshell, this is what
you need for most other commercial
flying jobs out there. And this one
lasts 12 calendar months, no matter what
age you are. Then once it expires, it
reverts to a third class medical
certificate. And this is something good
to keep in mind because if you're
interested in aviation as a career, you
might consider going ahead and getting a
secondass medical right off the bat to
make sure you can pass the exam. It's
nice to know that you can pass it
without any issues before you spend
thousands of dollars on training. They
don't usually cost much more and they
always revert to a third class when they
expire. And oddly enough, if you want to
be a flight instructor, you only need a
third class medical to do that. So, if
you don't have aspirations to go into
the airlines or any other type of
commercial stuff, but you want to teach,
you only have to have your third class
medical to do that. And the aviation
community can always use instructors who
actually enjoy teaching. Now, I do want
to mention that as someone pointed out
in the older version of this video,
technically the first and secondass
medicals don't revert to a lower
certificate. Yes, they are still
technically first and secondass medical
certificates, but the privileges you can
operate under are exactly the same as
the lesser medical. I'm just explaining
this in the easiest way possible for
people to understand. If you want more
details on that, check out this chart in
FAR 6123.
Okay, let's talk a little bit more about
the third class medical because this is
the one that you have to have before you
go solo if you're going for your private
pilot certificate. And you also have to
have it to operate legally as a private
pilot. And also, if you want to fly at
night as a sport pilot, you can also get
the third class medical. And this can
allow you to do that if you take the
proper training. The main thing you need
to know about the third class medical
certificate is how long it lasts before
it expires. And this depends on your
age. If you're less than 40, your third
class medical lasts 60 calendar months.
And if you're bad at math, that's 5
years. If you're 40 years and older,
your third class only lasts 24 calendar
months or 2 years. And remember, those
are calendar months. So it expires on
the last day of the month. So if you're
less than 40, you're good for 5 years.
If you're 40 and up, you only have two
years before you have to get your
certificate renewed. Really quickly,
let's look at how they might ask you a
question about this on the written exam.
You might even get asked about this on
your check ride. Let's say you have a
first class medical certificate that was
issued on November 11th and you're 20
years old. When does this medical
expire? Well, a first class medical
lasts 12 months if you're below 40. So,
this one expires next year on the 30th
of November. Then you could only use it
for third class privileges. What if I
was 55 years old and I had a secondass
medical certificate that was issued on
May 14th? When would that one expire?
Well, everyone expires at 12 calendar
months with the second class. So, that
one would expire on May 31st next year.
All right, here's a tricky one. Let's
say I'm 39 years old and I got my third
class medical issued on July 4th. When
does this one expire? Well, I'm below
40. So, it would expire on July 31st, 5
years from now because that's 60
calendar months. So, the important thing
to remember is that the expiration date
of a medical certificate depends on your
age. And once again, there's a handy
little chart in FAR 6123 that works
really well as a quick reference if you
ever need a quick reminder. One thing to
remember about these medical exams is
that they have to be done by a specific
doctor that have been designated by the
FAA. And these doctors are called
aviation medical examiners or AMEs. And
you can find a list of all the AMEs in
your area on the FAA's website. All
right, here we are on
www.faaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa.gov.
I'll just move down here to pilots and
airmen, then click on medical
certification. Then I'll click this
button that says locate an AM. Then I'll
just click this link that says search
for an aviation medical examiner AM in
your area. Now you can just search the
AM in your area and hopefully you can
find a good one. Okay, we've talked
about the three things you have to have
in your possession to be able to go fly
an aircraft. Now, let's take a closer
look at your pilot certificate because
your pilot certificate has to say
certain things on the back of it before
you can go fly certain types of
aircraft. To make this easier to
understand, let's take a quick step back
and talk about a few things. In order to
understand what you can and can't fly,
you first need to understand how we
group the different kinds of aircraft.
And the way we do this is by category
and class. When I'm talking about
aircraft, I'm basically talking about
anything that flies and can hold a
person. Yeah, I know a drone is an
aircraft, but it's an unmanned aircraft,
and those fall into a separate group.
Today, we're talking about manned
aircraft. And the FAA says that there
are seven main categories that you can
get certified to fly. For most of you
watching this video, you are probably
going to get your license to fly a
powered fixed-wing aircraft, and that's
what we call an airplane, in case you
didn't know that. Then if you want to go
fly helicopters or gyroplanes, you would
need to have a rotocraft category on the
back of your license. Keep in mind for
those of you going for your sport pilot
certificate, your license is not going
to have a category or a class on the
back of it. When you pass your check
ride, the FAA will send you an
endorsement that you can put in your log
book with the category and class that
you're allowed to fly. And if you want
to get an added category or class, you
have to take some training with an
approved instructor. and then when he
thinks you're ready, he can give you a
new endorsement that allows you to fly
that aircraft. Let's go back to talking
about categories. A glider is another
type of fixed wing aircraft, but this
one doesn't have an engine. Then, if you
wanted to fly a balloon as a private
pilot, you need your license to show
this lighter than air category on the
back. Then, we have the weight shift
control aircraft. A hang glider falls
into this category. Then, we have the
powered parachute. Then last but not
least, we have the powered lift
category, which would be like an Osprey
or a Harrier or something like that. I
doubt anyone here is trying to get that
category rating, but you never know.
Anyway, the big thing to know about this
is that once you get your private pilot
or sport pilot certificate, you can only
fly aircraft in the same category that
you are rated for. For example, if my
license says airplane on the back, I
can't just go jump into a rotor without
getting some training from an instructor
and take a check ride. Now, one cool
thing about the sport pilot rating is
once you have your sport pilot
certificate, you technically do not have
to take another check ride. You just
have to get training from an approved
instructor and then get endorsed by that
instructor to be able to fly those kinds
of aircraft, which is kind of crazy
considering the FAA is actually opening
up some types of helicopters to you guys
under the new Mosaic rule. But anyway,
from here, each category is further
divided into separate classes. For
example, in the airplane category, we've
got four main classes you can get your
certification on. These classes include
single engine land, single engine C,
multi-engine land, and multi-engine C.
Now, these classes exist for a reason.
The way you land a multi-engine land
airplane is significantly different than
the way you land a single engine C
airplane. So much so that the FAA has
decided that you need to get specific
training for these different airplanes
and take a check ride. So if your
license doesn't have a certain category
or a specific class of aircraft on it,
you can't just jump in and take off. And
once again, for you sport pilots, you
guys have to have an endorsement. Now,
for you helicopter nerds out there, you
basically have two classes of
rotorcraft. You've got the helicopter
and a gyroplane. So, if you've got your
helicopter license, you're going to have
to get some training before you can just
jump into a gyroplane. I don't know why
anyone would want that many moving parts
directly over their head. But if that's
what does it for you, go for it. Okay,
so we've got the main group of flying
thingies, and this is what we call
aircraft. Then below that, we've got
seven main categories. And then those
are further divided into different
classes. Then we can divide those up
even more into types. And these are
basically the exact make and model of
your aircraft. An example of a type
would be a Cesson 172 or a Piper
Cherokee 140 or a Dehavlin DHC2 Beaver.
And with that in mind, there are
actually certain types of aircraft that
you need a special rating to fly. We
call these type ratings. Basically, if
an airplane has a max gross weight
takeoff more than 12,500 lb or it has
turbo jet engines on it, you have to get
special training and take a check ride
before you can go fly it. But here's
something kind of interesting. You have
to have a type rating if the airplane
has a turbo jet on it, but you don't
have to have one for a turbo prop
airplane. The only exception is if that
airplane is over 12,500 lb. Then in that
case, you've got to have a type rating
like this one right here. According to
this guy's certificate, he's type rated
to fly the Beachcraft 400. Okay, we just
talked about all the paperwork you have
to have on board for you, the pilot.
Now, let's talk about all the paperwork
you have to have on board the aircraft
for the aircraft itself. Before we do,
though, I want to take a minute to talk
about the different categories of
aircraft. And I know this might seem a
little confusing since we just talked
about aircraft categories, but those
categories were for the purpose of a
pilot certification. These categories
are specifically referring to how an
aircraft is certified, and they
categorize airplanes based on how
they're going to be used. You can also
call these operating categories. When it
comes to aircraft certification
categories, there are five standard
kinds, but you only need to be familiar
with three of them as a private pilot or
a sport pilot. These are the normal,
utility, and acrobatic category. Right
about now, you're probably thinking,
"This sounds kind of familiar." And
you'd be right because we talked a
little bit about normal and utility
categories in my video on weight and
balance, but the one we didn't discuss
was the acrobatic category. Anyway, when
an aircraft is certified, it has to meet
certain criteria before it can be
certified in one of these categories.
For example, the normal category allows
aircraft to be used for normal everyday
flying. And it has to be able to do
certain things in order to be certified
in that category. For an aircraft to be
certified in the utility category, it
has to meet a few more requirements
because this category allows you to do
some additional maneuvers that the
normal category doesn't allow. For
example, this Cessna 172 Sierra is
certified in the utility category. So, I
could do spins if I wanted as long as I
stayed inside the weight and CG limits
for the utility category. Acrobatic
aircraft, on the other hand, are
specifically made for aerobatics. So,
these have to be even tougher and meet
more rigorous criteria. But as long as
it meets these specifications and the
FAA has full faith that the wings aren't
going to break off when you do a barrel
roll, then that's when it can get
certified as an acrobatic aircraft.
Okay, before we move on, let's briefly
look at a couple more categories. These
are special airworthiness certification
categories, and you should at least have
a general knowledge of a couple of
these. The experimental category is an
important one for you to remember
because this is the category that
homebuilt aircraft fall under. Now, the
big gotcha with these is that there are
quite a few restrictions when it comes
to experimental aircraft. For example,
you can't carry people or stuff for
hire, and you also can't operate them
over congested airways and over densely
populated areas. I could go on for quite
a while, but you'll find a complete list
of these in FAR 91319.
If you're hoping to build your own
airplane like I am one day, you'll want
to write that down for future reference.
Next, we have the light sport. These are
basically sport aircraft that don't
really fit into the homebuilt ultralight
or gyroplane category. Under the new
mosaic rule, an aircraft can be
certified under the light sport category
as long as it has a stall speed of 61
knots or less, 59 knots with the flaps
extended. It also must have a max cruise
speed of 250 knots or less. And the
aircraft can now have up to four seats
if it's an airplane. All other aircraft
have to be two seats or less. Aircraft
in the restricted category are aircraft
that aren't typically allowed to fly
over densely populated areas. These are
usually crop dusters and fire support
aircraft. And the reason these are
called restricted is because they're
basically restricted on where they can
fly. Now, as you saw, there are a couple
other ones, but those aren't really
important to you right now. So, let's
move on and talk about the aircraft
documents that you need to have on board
the aircraft when you go fly. I want to
reiterate that all these documents that
we're about to discuss need to be in the
airplane. They can't just be in the
hanger where you keep the plane. And to
remember these documents, I like to use
the acronym arrow. For the first two
items, you'll find these requirements in
FAR 91203.
Now, as you can see here, the A in the
arrow stands for airworthiness
certificate. What the heck is an
airworthiness certificate? This
basically just tells the world that you
didn't just weld a bunch of crap
together and make something that's going
to fall out of the sky when it breaks
apart. This document basically says that
the FAA has approved this design and
it's certified in these categories over
here. As you can see, this airplane is
certified in the normal and utility
category. It's not certified in the
acrobatic category. So, arerobatics are
out of the question because it will
probably break in half if you try to do
an implan or some other crazy maneuver.
Anyway, one other thing I want to
mention about the airworthiness
certificate is that it doesn't have an
expiration date. Now, just because the
aircraft has an airworthiness
certificate, that doesn't make it
airworthy. If you start making illegal
changes to the airplane or don't
maintain it in the way that's legally
required to be maintained, it's no
longer airworthy. But that's a lesson
for another day. Next, we have the
registration. This is just like the
registration on a car. You buy an
airplane and you get it registered. And
that just tells the FAA and everyone
else out there who owns the aircraft.
That way, if you do something stupid,
anyone can look up your in number and
tattle on you. And there are good things
about this as well. If you were to crash
your plane or something and they knew
the tail number, they at least would
have a starting point on who to contact.
Okay, so the registration on an aircraft
does expire and it lasts 84 calendar
months or 7 years after the previous
expiration date. So if the previous
registration expired in November, the
next registration will expire on the
last day of November, seven years from
then. Now for the next R&R ARO acronym,
that doesn't really apply here in the
US, but if you're overseas somewhere,
you typically need a radio operator's
license. The O and our arrow acronym
stands for operating limits, and you'll
find this requirement in FAR 91.9.
As you can see here, we must comply with
the operating limits of our aircraft.
And there are two things we need to have
to help us to do that. First, there must
be a current and approved airplane or
rocraft flight manual on board if there
was one made for the aircraft. I like to
call this the P or pilots operating
handbook. If there wasn't a PO made for
your aircraft, there has to be some kind
of approved manual or placards or a
combination of the two. Okay. One other
thing I want to mention is that if you
do fly an experimental or light sport
aircraft, sometimes you'll find those
operating limits attached to the
airworthiness certificate. And a lot of
times you'll find more details in there
about what you can and can't do in those
aircraft. Last but not least, we have to
have our weight and balance. Now,
technically this falls under the
operating limits. So, there isn't an
actual regulation that specifically
mentions the word weight and balance,
but the FAA has made it clear in other
publications that weight and balance is
required when you're talking about those
operating limits. I went into a lot more
detail on this in my video on weight and
balance. So, if you haven't watched that
video yet, be sure to check that one
out. Hey, thanks for joining me today on
free pilot training. I hope you enjoyed
this video. If you did, please consider
checking out freepilotraining.net
[music]
net where you'll find all kinds of cool
pilot gear and a ton of other resources
[music] that will help you on your
journey to become a pilot. It also makes
it possible for me to make videos just
like this. And if you buy yourself a
cool shirt like this one, it also lets
your friends know that you're a pilot.
We all know they need another reminder.
In the next video, I'm going to go into
more detail on basic med because a lot
of people going for their sport and
private pilot certificate are telling me
that there's a lot of questions about
that on the written exam. So, [music]
I'll put that video right here. Thanks
for watching.
[groaning]